hey guys I'm Charlotte Assad and you're
watching my reviews of dead space 3 and
Crysis 3 I'm also going to be giving
away an Xbox at the end of this video so
stay tuned until the end if you want to
check that out
sorry dead space 3 it follows the story
of Isaac Clark who's an engineer who's
destroyed a few of an ancient technology
called macas he's supposed to do so once
again so heads off to a planet called
tau volantis and just his luck is
absolutely full with flesh-hungry
monsters that being said Dead Space 3 is
really not a stereo game at all there's
too many resources around for you to
really fear death and it's kind of
obvious why enemies will come from but
it does make itself worth playing for
completely different reasons even if
it's just so you can stomp the heads of
your enemies or tear off limbs like the
sadistic ballast you truly are the
combat is really really smooth and
incredibly customisable in fact I'd say
the best thing about Dead Space 3 is its
crafting you can farm 4 items or even
purchase them in my current transactions
if you suck but you'll automatically
come across various parts throughout the
game and there are tons of blueprints
readily available if you don't want to
make your own it's from gold sores to
acid shooting guns there's pretty much
no limit on what you can make at the
same time you can also customize your
reload times rate of fire and damage so
you can really choose how fast you want
the combat to be aside from that Dead
Space 3 is quite far from being a
perfect game the characters are horrible
the relationships are even worse Isaac's
really slowly the missions are kind of
repetitive there's a lot of go here find
this over and over and over again and
there's random Oh balls all the time
where you're sort of just walking there
are a few years sort of unfitting boss
fights as well where the weak point on
the box glows bright gold so it's really
hard to miss and they sort of just
appear kind of randomly yeah even so
even if you just want to play something
without a HUD because that is absolutely
amazing
really pretty game I highly recommend
this through sci-fi fans or anyone who's
looking for a really unique third-person
shooter now Crysis 3 is equally heavy on
aliens and suits the main character
profit has gone through some pretty
weird stuff you'll know what I'm saying
if you've played the previous games but
basically his high-tech suit is what
keeps him alive at first the story feels
a little bit absent but as the very
short campaign goes on it becomes kind
of exciting the Nanosuit the Prophet is
wearing allows him to go invisible to
sometimes go invincible and to harden
kind of like a metapod but a lot more
useful and I spent a very large majority
of this game with my invisibility on
with my predator bow so if a bow is an
amazing weapon it one hit kills
everything for a ridiculous range and
has a lovely array of arrows that
Electric - explosive and then your
regular combat hit your visor just like
the camera in Far Cry 3 tells you
exactly where are your enemies are so
long as you tag them it gives a little
golden red arrow above their head so you
can track their movement so you can even
upgrade your suit to track their actual
steps and for those of you who thought
baccarat threes rook island was pretty
man do you need to play crysis 3 it's
set in an urban jungle in new york city
where everything is overrun by cell
operatives and aliens and it looks so
real it's the most realistic looking
game I have ever played
I'm not a big FPS fan but it's a game I
really have trouble flooring I thought
Crysis 3 was amazing because it really
makes you feel like a predator it's kind
of scary how awesome it is to have all
of these people so afraid of you all the
time now for those of you paying
attention I have mentioned one word that
I normally wouldn't three times in this
videos that word is a clue to help you
crack the code for Xbox Australia's
second crack the code competition Xbox
releases clues for this competition
every few days on their Facebook page so
that one lucky winner whoever cracks the
code will win an awesome prize I'll
leave a link and some more details in
the description below and with that I
have won Xbox
sixty slim with connect2give away this
is only open to Australian residents and
you must be subscribed to my channel you
can make a one minute video or tell me
in 25 words or less if you could pick
any suit from any game comic book or
even just a movie what would you pick
and why my competition is closing on the
20th of March so make sure you get your
answers in before then and I will be
messaging the lucky wanting to get the
address so we can send them off an Xbox